this is Jocko underground podcast number
67 Echo Charles sitting across from me
so the expression
what do they say about these expressions
the expression is you are the average of
the five people you hang around with the
most you know that expression yeah
something along those lines there's a
couple different versions of it floating
around
but it's common
and the reason it's common is because
there's some level of truth to it I
think we can agree on that
and as I'm thinking through that
I think I I agree there is truth and you
can tell uh you know
what you see remember high school and
you'd see a kid start to hang around
with a new group that he wasn't involved
with before and he starts to act like
that group
did your school have like the jocks yeah
the
the whatever burnouts right yeah you
probably had Surfers yeah like so you so
you got these groups and you could see a
kid that was not in that group goes in
that group and starts to become like
that group so we've all seen that so
there's there is a level of truth to
this statement
but it doesn't stop there because
it's not just who we're hanging around
with but what are we allowing into our
heads yeah what are we allowing to get
in there
because
at a minimum
we're highly influenced I know that's a
little bit of a weird way of saying it
right at a minimum we're highly
influenced but at a minimum
we're
definitely influenced by what we allow
into our heads what kind of music we're
listening to what kind of movies we're
watching what kind of social media which
is bizarre because you can you can pull
social media into your head all the time
and these things have a real impact on
you
music for instance now we know I'm a big
music fan I'm a big music listener music
can reduce anxiety music can reduce
blood pressure these are physiological
things that can happen from music
can reduce pain
these are physiological things that can
happen music can improve Sleep Quality
Music can improve mood music can improve
mental alertness
music can improve memory these are not
I'm not just saying oh I think it does
no it does
there's also research that some music
can increase aggressive thoughts so if
you listen to kind of music I listen to
that makes sense maybe maybe it can
there's there's evidence that music
encourages certain types of music
Encourage crime
right
so there's good and bad going on kind of
like fire right fire can heat your house
it can burn your house to the ground
but it's something that we need to pay
attention to so
so we have to be selective
as to what we allow to get in our head
and we have to be selective as to who
we're going to hang around with and we
have to be selective as to what we
listen to We have to be selective as to
what we read
we have to be selective as to what we're
going to allow into our heads
you gotta get rid of the junk at some
point and listen
you know you have this argument you can
listen to I listen to music with Crazy
lyrics Right Crazy lyrics that never
impacted me to do anything crazy you
know whether it's uh
lyrics about you know anti-social lyrics
anti-government lyrics whatever criminal
look whatever it is there's lyrics and I
go oh I love that song I wasn't like hey
I'm gonna follow the political beliefs
in this song right yeah
so
I'm not saying you gotta just not listen
to anything right
or you gotta only listen to the stuff
with the positive but you got to pay
attention to it
the you gotta increase the volume of
constructive pragmatic input to your
brain and you've got to limit the volume
of negative harmful adverse things that
you lie on your brain now I also think
this I think if you're paying attention
to it it's not going to have that much
of an impact so if you're listening to
some music that has real negative
message to the lyrics but you know that
I think you're gonna be okay if you
don't know that or you're not paying
attention to it that's when it can catch
you off guard same thing with social
media if you're watching social media or
looking at social media with uh with a
questioning eye
that's gonna be a lot better than if
you're looking at it with not an
unquestioning eye
and what's really scary right now
obviously is that algorithm the way that
thing works
it's looking to give you the short-term
gratification it's looking to put you
into that Echo chamber it's
it's what we need to pay attention to
so let's take the expression of you're
the average of the five people you hang
around with the most which I think we
can all anecdotally prove
just from people you've known and you've
watched them change
and if we pay attention to that and we
see how it works then we see that
everything we let in our brain if you're
not paying attention to it can move you
so watch out
watch out you listen to Ozzy Osbourne
yeah totally so did you ever
there was like this conspiracy theory
hold on just just to make this clear the
band Black Sabbath that Ozzy Osbourne
was the lead singer of is my favorite
band of all time and
I've seen them in concert I've listened
to all of their albums especially the
years with Ozzy and I still listen to
them when they had deal but yes I am
completely and utterly uh engrossed in
Black Sabbath and I have been since a
young child
and yes I remember I think so I think we
were going with Ozzy Osbourne got sued
in the
80s
he had a song called Suicide Solution
and uh I don't have the D I don't
remember the details but he ended up
going to court
but the weird thing about the song the
song wasn't saying suicide was a
solution it was actually not about that
at all you know the the one of the
lyrics the famous lyrics is
wine is fine but Whiskey's quicker
suicide is slow with liquor right so
you're saying you're if you're drinking
you're killing himself and look this is
coming from a guy that had drug problems
and alcohol problems so he was saying
I'm killing myself not I should kill
myself yeah
uh so what you what were you gonna say
before I interrupted you there there's a
conspiracy theory
um and it might have just came out of
this that scenario which I didn't know
did not know
um that if you played I forget I don't
know what song If you play it backwards
yeah it's called back masking
yeah and it's not just Aussie there's
all kinds and the Beatles actually had
that so let me rephrase that I'm pretty
sure because I used to play The Beatles
records backwards looking for this stuff
yeah there's one that said Paul is dead
uh stuff like that yeah they back mask
into the lyrics yep yeah they were like
oh yeah you play Ozzy backwards uh and
it's like devil worship and then you end
up killing yourself or something like
that I don't think that was a rumor at
you know your high school or whatever it
was straight up yeah but but there there
are but the Beatles definitely backmash
I'm saying definitely I hate saying
definitely but I'm pretty sure that when
I was a kid we played
we played
Beatles backwards and you just put it on
the record and you use your finger to
pull to rotate it backwards yeah and it
would be the ball is dead you know
something like that which is just random
stuff to put in there there's called
back masking and yes it's a thing when
you play it backwards that's when you
when you put it in there oh you put some
back masking messages in there oh when
you record it or whatever oh okay damn
see I didn't know that there there's a
movie called The Gate you ever watch
that movie boy it's back in those days
by the way where that was one of the
like part of the premise of the movie
like if you played this one think
backwards it opened the gate to hell it
was actually a pretty fun movie unless
um that so is this true about Ozzy
Osbourne where at one of his concerts he
bit the head off of uh yes bat was it
yeah so that's true yep oh he was Psycho
there and what it was I there's there's
a couple different versions of it and
again I apologize my memories you know
filled with half of the rumors and half
of the lies and half of the truth
whatever that's three halves I don't
know how it's gonna turn out but we have
but yeah because I heard him tell the
story of he would they had like rubber
bats or something
and he would bite the head off all the
wall like a big stage show but then at
some point someone threw him a real one
and uh and he also
in a record label meeting
bit the head off of a dog or something I
think I remember hearing that story as
well oh yeah but that's a wild guy man
that's wild times man so Black Sabbath
Ozzy back in the day do you still listen
to it has a song called Ordinary man
yeah it's pretty new pretty new when the
last few is pretty solid oh yeah they're
great I mean I I think that Black
Sabbath is the greatest rock and roll
band of all time what's the best song
Crazy Train no that's not even Black
Sabbath that's Aussie no uh uh just the
entire first like Five albums oh damn
yeah and there's very few bands that
have made
album after album after album that were
all good that were all awesome it's like
you got
Black Sabbath
Led Zeppelin
AC DC
Metallica like they made
because a lot of bands make a good album
yeah
yeah and then that's what they got you
know and the other ones are okay
sometimes the other ones aren't that
good but to come out with that many
really great albums is difficult to do
and not many bands have pulled that off
yeah
freaking Aussie
um the who you hang with or whatever and
that totally makes sense or even like
you know how like you I'll catch you
talking pigeon every once in a while
sometimes yeah and that's just so but
it's like that even if it's I mean they
say it's like just five
but even if you hang with one guy you
can you'll probably like if you just do
a small little inventory like you'll see
like all the little things that you do
like them now kind of a thing and vice
versa so Brad that makes total sense a
lot of people like to say the um you
know the cool catchphrase is like oh
show me your network and I'll show you
your net worth or like that kind of
stuff which
think I actually agree with you I think
there's some a lot of truth to it a lot
of the time but it's it's you know it
depends a lot of a lot of the time
especially the net worth part but yeah
that's true so be careful right what you
put in your head one time I was hanging
around with a guy that I knew was
friends with part of my network
if I was still in the Navy
and he was rolling in like uh brand new
Mercedes S-Class
AMG like like a 250 000 car maybe 200
000 car yeah
and I had a 1997 Dodge Grand Caravan the
window didn't work so his net worth was
wasn't enough
you know what I'm saying that can be
real too for sure but hey that's the way
it works watch out and the modern
um another modern issue with what you
let in your head and you know so
essentially it's like be careful what
you let in your head it's up to you what
you let in your head where like can you
mentioned the algorithm and I think
that's a bigger thing than uh sometimes
than what people realize because like if
you're like okay
um well it depends on what you look at
but let's say you follow a certain
person right where you're like oh I like
what they have to say I don't know
Jordan Peterson or I don't know you know
Andrew Tate is a hot one right now
whatever
so it doesn't matter who I'm just saying
like you start to the algorithm would be
like oh you like this guy oh here's more
from this guy here's more from this guy
and then instead of when you originally
like just what they said you start to
like the person now now it doesn't
matter what they say they can say some
weird stuff and you're just like well I
like him so hell yeah that's me too you
know so you kind of sign on to all their
stuff after a while that can't happen
yeah you better be careful of that you
got to be careful like but yeah how are
you saying if you if you're always like
what do you call a questioning always a
question yep you know what I think
so we made an album if you remember this
it was called psychological warfare yeah
and that album really a lot of people
got it and still get it to this day and
what's interesting about that is
that's so that's that's doing exactly
what this is talking about putting good
thoughts into your head yeah right I'm
gonna overcome this
that's
you can see why that album has been so
popular because people go oh if you
listen that when you wake up in the
morning that's the first thing that's in
your head and then you take the whole
thing like we we talked about on the
machete season
the machete season podcast where they
talk about the power of radio and the
power of spoken word and how there's no
filter it goes right into your brain you
don't need to convert anything and
that's what psychological warfare is
it's it's it's help people overcome
those moments of weakness and help
people stay on the path why is that
because they're putting something into
their head that's moving them in the
right direction yeah
yeah it's like helping in the real world
yeah so but then you got to be careful
because like you just said you can get
on the gram and be like Oh I'm gonna go
get some positivity from the gram next
thing you know
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground